well so far the the process has been
very expensive it's taken about 10 years
to get through various different courts
to this point but the Guardian is is now
won the case of the Supreme Court and I
think that the the last public figures
on this were that there was around 270
thousand pounds worth of costs and the
government racked up so it's been a very
expensive and I'll be further cost on
top of that I think it's been a very
expensive process I'm presuming you have
to pay your side of the costs as well so
we can we can double that I think that
stills to be settled actually though no
doubt the lawyers there are still
working on around that now has it been
worth it in the end all that effort and
all that money for what we've discovered
in these letters well I think there's a
couple of things that make it worth it
one is the the the depth of
understanding you can get from the
letters here about the way that Prince
Charles has operated in the past and
possibly still operates with government
ministers in terms of pushing his own
agendas and trying to get involved in
policy debates the the complexity with
which II which he does that the detailed
which he does that and also the sort of
demanding nature of some of his letters
about wanting to see things done and
also wanting to get his own aides and
advisers involved in the policy debate I
mean he clearly has privileged access he
is the heir to the throne at the same
time the opinions he expresses are
pretty run-of-the-mill aren't they and
is there much evidence that they had in
any impact on government well I think
you're right I mean the to the extent
that a lot of the things he raises are
things that we know he was already
interested in whether it's architecture
or complementary medicine you know or
Patagonian toothfish all the way up to
defense and the his demands around you
know replacement for the Lynx helicopter
but I think what you can see in some of
the letters is we're going through them
now is that you know ministers including
Tony Blair responding very positively to
his suggestions and they are saying that
we will take on boards
advise that you are willing to give us
and that was notable in this in the
price bothers about complementary
medicines so I think you know that there
is clearly a message coming out of these
letters that government is certainly at
that point took him seriously often
they're trying to you know modify in to
some extent I think and say look I don't
necessarily agree with what you're
saying but you know this is what the box
is and this is where we're going but
there's very open communication and in
some cases there seems to be a you know
kind of willingness to adapt to his
views that do you at the Guardian think
there's actually something inappropriate
about what's been revealed about the
printers behavior and his influence well
I think I think the view is that I mean
people take different views of the
Guardian on that I think I think one of
the most important things in this
transparency around the the way that he
communicates with the government and
that this is a important part of
achieving that sort of transparency and
I think it becomes more and more
important actually as it gets closer and
closer to being King especially if he
intends as some people seem to think he
does to become more of an activist King
than his mother would be because of
course when the Erinyes is as a result
of this legal action that governments
now change the law and the monarch and
the heir to the throne have absolute
privilege and any future communications
will be kept private well yeah that
change has made some some years ago I've
been and they did indeed introduce an
absolute exemption and and that makes it
very difficult as you say for us to to
find out more about that and I don't
think that's something that's to be
welcomed I mean I think
perhaps all journalists would say this
but I think the public would feel it too
that if he is going to take a part in
public life we need to find perhaps some
way of understanding more about that in
a way theirs is acceptable to the public
as well as the government in the world
family